hello I'm gav I'm we're the slowmo guys
on a firing range on an exceptionally
bright day which is what we need for
slow-mo do you remember that old footage
of bullets at million frames a second
was black and white maybe like 12 years
ago I think it was longer than 12 years
you're old now I'm old maybe longer than
years ago I do remember it and I
remember thinking how mindblowing it was
I thought it was fake cuz it was like
unheard of frame rates at that time I
think it was a shimatsu black and white
camera so extremely high frame rate but
extremely short duration recording I was
started filming with and we were doing
sort of maybe a th000 frames a second
yeah and that's sort of the limit of
what we could do at the time right and I
was like how are they get in 10 why
don't you have that why do we have that
camera but now we have a camera that
could do 1.75 million I figured we could
try and get some of that footage
ourselves I've never shot anything like
that just really nice closeup of bullets
just splashing all over this and we'll
try and we'll try and push to the limits
of this camera push it to the Limit
um so so today we've got your standard 9
mil ball round we used these before also
got a hollow point we not used these yet
and step it up a notch we've now got a
as the Americans would say 30 or 6 okay
which is considerably beefier okay so we
thought it might be interesting before
we see bullets bounced off metal it
might be interesting to see a bullet go
through metal well hopefully go through
metal this is an aluminium baking tray I
finished making some cookies and uh now
we're going to try and see if a 9 mil
will punch through here I've got a 200
mil ens on the TMX 7510 just so that we
can fill the frame with that Target
without being right next to it and then
it's going to shoot from back here
you're a pretty good shot aren't you
feel like a lot of people with the
comments are like bloody out he can nail
these shots I guess I don't you know you
will say that and I'll just miss
completely all right well the first shot
we'll start at 82,000 so you have the
freedom of the entire plate being in
frame and then we'll crop down as we get
faster so it's going to become more
difficult as we go on oh good loaded
made
ready made a really neat little
hole wow it's like a splash in a pond
like you barely noticed anything like
you just chucked a little Stone into a a
puddle I guess it stole a little piece
of the baking trick oh yeah these Baker
tray is
likey it's interesting that whenever you
see like an exit wound like that you
just assume all the materials just
peeled out but I never seem to think
that there's like a tiny little bit
missing yeah there's a whole Ripple
going through the rest of the baking
tray but the second the bullet stops
touching this bit it's just Rock Steady
oh that's weird isn't it and it doesn't
go Beyond the bullet it's not like
ballistic gel where it'll go through and
then send it Way Beyond it literally
just goes opens with the bullet and
hangs in place yeah just stays there now
let's see what half an inch of Steel
does yeah a lot I think I should think
so
head
ready yep bloody bang in the middle
living up to the rep already you can see
the splash already from the from the
hollow point the bullet is done what
it's designed to do and it's broken up
and you can see the individual bits of
like fragmentation that have come off it
oh you can see it coming in out of focus
out of focus coming into Focus here clap
wow just turned into a pieces immed
every direction yeah I don't think
anything really came back look you've
still got the the center part there is
basically just the only part that has
come back and even after the impact it's
still rifling but the lead is still
spinning in that direction yeah look
that's the more dangerous part is the
center of the bullet the copper
definitely just nothing of it just all
went to the side and then the lead came
back this is really interesting you know
the shape of the hollow point the shape
of the front mhm wow Sparks in that P
interesting I wonder if it's the gaps
between the metal or yeah I think it's
the pieces that have hit first so where
it like goes in they're not sparking yet
oh so the actual the forward pieces
there's six of them 1 2 3 four five six
yeah and then you can see get one frame
of they it's like it's like a banana
skin yeah this frame rate seems to be
one 2 three four frames until the back
of the bullet hits the steel Target
that's
sweet okay
what do you think of our new
frame
oh okay well if I frame up on the the
Splat which it is we'll know whether you
hit in the frame or not based on if it's
in line with that Splat
okay good I can see it just coming into
frame you didn't give me much room did
you no look at that you can see the
pieces more clearly there that's great
that's a pretty good frame rate for this
actually yeah what was that 400,000 400
,000 I mean we're not remember we're not
as close as the black and white camera
yeah like that their theirs was so good
because it was so close yeah we do have
a nice bit of color going on there as
well got color speaking of color let's
go black and white and see how fast we
can go so I think the only way for us to
get closer based on this current setup
is to just slightly angle the steel yeah
I mean you got two sort of danger areas
with these bullets is the plane of the
steel itself cuz that's where all the
the copper and lots of bits of
fragmentation are going is on the plane
of the the seal and then the central
lead part because I'm directly in front
of it seems to be just bouncing directly
back off again yeah so you kind of want
to be at 45° sort of safe from both of
those areas with the camera
loaded made
ready I might have hit it through the
same hole either that or I missed
completely are you bloody
RoboCop
bangang oh here we go I can see the
bullet coming in now coming into Focus
God it's moving so slowly look at it
just chilling D wow great shot though
Central is knobs it's just showing so
much detail that's so similar to the the
old footage I think we're like mildly
achieving with a less scientific setup
but uh you think this is
scientific we're on a hinged table with
a piece of metal in a quarry should we
see how it compares to a regular regular
90 bog standard nine sure I wonder if
there'll be much of a difference really
I think there'll just be a difference in
this The Flash at the front you think so
so I've uh managed to pick up some 9 mil
Tracer rounds which have got this little
bit of sort of red tip paint on there
and it's got a little composition of
Tracer in the back might be a ring or it
might be solid I'm not sure so uh we'll
see that when we see a bullet
approaching oh yeah a little bit of
burning action it's not that bright
though it definitely ejects whatever was
on it out of the back these rounds are
doing more damage to the Target they're
leaving different impression well sort
of cold at first but you warmed to it
yeah should we uh do the rifle it's a
heavier round or heavier bullet a lot
longer different profile lot faster so I
wonder if we'll get more frames of it
splatting or whether because it's
because it's longer but also it's faster
so it might just be the same amount well
it's twice the speed it's twice the
length but twice the speed it might be
four frames of splat again it's going to
be exactly the same much further away
now yeah got a longer range rifle which
is more powerful so we have to move back
a lot yeah camera is still over there
though in our in between our dangerous
angles it's in the safe window not safe
enough for us to stand there absolutely
not let me know when you're ready I am
ready
okay did you hear that no what was it it
went I heard like a t
because it was the rebound of the sound
I
think
clip what what
oh B what the
thing The Ting you heard was it hitting
this what after it went through oh my
God I did not expect that that is nuts
that's unreal all right hold on let me
go get the camera cuz we're we're ants
on this Frame wait wait wait hold on
hold
on what so what I think has happened on
first glance is it's just breezed
through like nothing and made a hole
twice the size of the actual bullet it's
like pushed it to the side and gone move
out the way and then this other sign
just happened to be behind it yeah and
it hit that and didn't go through yeah
look this thin aluminium sign and it's
just sort of mildly dented it just gone
like bang ah and just like tinged off
this thin bit of aluminium it's weird
though the the exit is cleaner than the
entrance you know I didn't expect that
the back is neat and it's like a soft
tip round it's that much more
powerful
flip
booking wa look at the amount of wait so
it destroyed it pretty much look at the
that's the lead in the middle of the
that's why it caused a bigger I would
love to it seems like it was just enough
steel it's it's it might be the perfect
size of Steel cuz you see the the the
fact that the the hole is bigger than
the bullet yeah it's because what
happened is it deformed when it hit the
steel and a load of the copper jacket
came backwards even this jacket's
rifling does every piece of bullet
continue to spin after impact just
carried on through and made a bigger
hole I don't think any of the copper
went through no it just all like left
that's like lead and steel we can't
really do precise speed measurements on
the shot cuz of the angle yeah should we
just put the camera at 90 yeah put the
camera at night put far away though
wouldn't it uh well it's all coming out
it's not really coming out the side it's
going through and backwards it's going
forwards and backwards so potentially
our angles of Danger on this one is only
backwards yeah there's not a lot of
spread let's watch it again make sure
ready
yep
here she comes book Central
rapid wow that's they just like it turn
it's like a little transformation booth
and and it has like a cloud of dust
that's the same shape as it covered out
the other side yeah that's mental the
big old chunk came back yeah it's all
the jacket all the jacket just gets PE
the Jack out yeah it just peels away and
then the lead comes out the other side
it's like a lead sorting office like it
just sorts the lead from the from the
jacket it's crazy that that's the effect
it has on the target the the the jacket
gets peeled away goes backwards and the
lead just carries on and makes a big
exit wound basically just creates a big
hole should we try and get a shot of the
exit with that yeah just maybe angle it
45 and shoot from I'll shoot over there
over there
yeah I think this angle's revealing
something oh yeah have a look oh here
she
comes wa it like deforms it is that
actually the steel not the lead yeah
that big chunk is just spoiling and the
bullet is actually right next to it the
flat rear piece of the bullet also still
rifling oh so it's just pushing it out
yeah it's like when you have like one of
those cardboard cutout things you know
the pop push pop things you go like that
it's just doing that to the steel like
so the jacket seems to come out straight
backwards and the lead it's just
fragmenting the bullet and kicking steel
out there was that's so I don't think
the bullet is technically going through
as a bullet that's interesting it's
amazing that we filmed this from two
other angles and couldn't figure that
out yeah like it's actually important to
just do loads of coverage of this CU
there's there's stuff to be learned from
every angle so
essentially it's still doing exactly the
same thing as the 9 mil it's just
hitting it with more Force yeah we're
not testing different hardnesses we're
testing different like velocities and
power deliveries because if we had like
an armor piercing round then the armor
piercing round would go through the
steel right and it would still be yeah
right hole but it's just doing the same
thing as the 9 mil except three four
five times as more powerful that's crazy
that was done by a bit of steel Target
oh yeah so the steel we that sign has
not been shot or hit by a bullet yeah
this is just a Target that we found on
the floor here yeah we just found this
on the floor assuming it's steel of
similar width I think it's slightly
thinner actually I can test it but I
think it's slightly thinner but based
off the fact that it's got no holes in
it I assume it's actually capable of
whis standing our serious round
potentially however I think these
targets are meant to like be hit and
sort of give way to show that they've
been hit so there's like a little bit
more give in them cuz it's supposed to
be like attached to something they go
like but we've just rocked solidly
clamped it down so maybe that'll have an
effect I'm not sure so we've basically
set it on hard mode we've set it on like
and if it survives this it's really good
pretty
much just ripped it
out
oh there we go no chance of going
through that gosh and look at this the
sun is shining through the shock wave
giving us almost like aaren effect you
can see the wave in front and behind the
bullet it it's pretty much the same
every time we film this we get
completely new information look at the
flaps of the the steel Target flapping
[Music]
about
it's just made like a dent yeah that's
not even that's like the equivalent of
the 9 mil on the the steel that I got
and this is only this is 10 mil thick
and the steel we got is 13 mil thick so
it's thicker because it's not as hard
and not meant to be a Target it just
blew straight through it so we've got I
think we got the best of both world's
footage here we've
got yeah going through and bouncing off
for the same round that's really
interesting the same essentially the
same thing steel yeah it's just behaved
so differently that's wild is it just
the manufacturing process uh yeah I
think so it's just the hardness rating
of the
steel
that was a pinger oh oh no oh no it
shattered the vice now that's a
transference of energy I've had that
thing through thick and thin wow look
it's just sheared it just clean sheared
that that it's
nuts a you sad are you upset yeah little
bit it's all right B thanks I'll get you
a new one
cheers
perfect that's fine that's absolutely
fine absolute frame filler look at
that that was some class looking footage
it was awesome it reminded me exactly of
that old black and white stuff from
decade plus ago and now I fully believe
that it wasn't CGI it was definitely
real it was real obviously our stuff was
shot from further away um we couldn't
make the bullets as big in frame just
because I don't want to annihilate our
lenses and camera but I'm pretty happy
with what we got to be honest I think it
looks great yeah it's interesting to see
the pattern it made in the steel and the
difference in the rounds is just
unbelievable yeah the these punched all
the way through and these I would say
barely a millimeter barely a Mill and
this is what it looks like when you hit
like a tank with a kinetic round it just
creates a splash in the metal yeah just
like a frozen Rock Solid Splash yeah and
then there's spoiling on this side of
all the all the metal that's just got
chucked off that's m wasn't it yeah well
I thoroughly enjoyed filming that much
faster bullet if you would like us to
revisit any of our previous 9 mil videos
let us know in the comments and we'll
see if we can hurl a few of these into
it it's like the difference between the
4k camera and the TMX it's just a
different thing it's a different animal
isn't it I was very surprised yeah me
too hopefully you enjoyed that video
make sure you subscribe if you're into
slowmo and here's another video for you
to watch see you next time bye-bye